one year ago today many americans woke
up with fresh hope the first vaccines
had been administered for some it seemed
like the beginning of the end
but now one year later more people have
died since the vaccine was available
than before 500 000 people bringing the
death toll in the u.s to more than 800
thousand and with the new omicron
variant that is more contagious
officials are warning that another spike
in cases is coming but mostly for the
unvaccinated
our booster vaccine regimens work
against omicron at this point there is
no need for a variant specific booster
it's gotten so bad in the state of
minnesota that hospitals took out this
full-page ad practically begging people
to get vaccinated writing we're
heartbroken we're overwhelmed dr kenneth
holman signed the letter
they are disappointed
upset
angry
frustrated saddened you take the entire
range of humor emotion human emotion and
you will see it in our staff
and we have to remember to continue to
continue to care for our patients no
matter
where they come from
what their vaccination status is
and the spike is having real world
consequences some universities are going
back online sports games being postponed
or cancelled as more than 100
professional basketball football and
hockey players have been diagnosed with
covid
the u.s secretary of state had to return
early from his trip to asia after a
reporter on his plane tested positive
leading officials to urge people to take
precautions we should be having public
indoor masking for everyone vaccinated
or unvaccinated that is 90 percent of
the counties right now
but only eight states have mandated
masks indoors and several states have
outright banned requiring masks more
proof that in the u.s the pandemic is
still a political issue one that is
having deadly consequences
pat culhane al jazeera washington